نريد أن نتحدث إلى العالم بأسره
من نحن
من نحن بحلول الوقت الذي انطلق فيه أيمن
الزواحي إلى الساحة العالمية بعد
اغتيال الرئيس المصري
أنور السادات ، كان بالفعل إرهابيًا
ملتزمًا بتحويل مصر إلى
دولة إسلامية أصولية.
جاء طبيب من إحدى
العائلات المصرية البارزة ، حتى أنه يوجد
شارع للزاواري في القاهرة سمي على اسم
جده وصفه عمه
بأنه تقوى ، وكان معروفًا أنه مسلم
صالح يحرص
على
أداء الصلاة
في المسجد وهكذا
و  للقراءة والتفكير
ولاتخاذ قراراته الخاصة ، قضى الزواهي ثلاث
سنوات في السجن بعد
اغتيال السادات بعد خروجه ، وشق
طريقه إلى باكستان حيث استخدم
مهاراته الطبية لعلاج أولئك الذين يقاتلون
الاحتلال السوفيتي
لأفغانستان حيث كان هناك.  قابلت أسامة بن لادن
ووجدوا سببًا مشتركًا تحدث
عنه بعد عقد من الزمان نحن
نعمل مع أخ لادن نعرفه
منذ أكثر من عامين
تحدثنا معه معها.  في أفغانستان
ونحن نعمل معه في السودان
والعديد من الأماكن الأخرى ، وكان الزواري العديد من
الأماكن في أوائل التسعينيات حتى
يعتقد أنه كان يزور كاليفورنيا
بجواز سفر مزور ، هاجمت مجموعته
السفارات المصرية وحاولت قتل السياسيين المصريين في
نهاية المطاف.  إن مجموعته
في القاعدة الزواهري قادت إلى حد كبير
المجموعة التي نفذها
السياسة الإستراتيجية لما كانت أجندة القاعدة
بالتأكيد منحها بن لادن
سلطته وبركاته لكن الظواهري
أطلق الرصاص على الزاوية كان في
جانب بن لادن عندما  أعلن الحرب على
أمريكا في مايو 1998. وبعد أسابيع ،
شنوا هجومًا على سفارات الولايات المتحدة في
إفريقيا ثم ابتهجوا بعد أن
نجوا من هجوم بصاروخ كروز أمريكي تم
شنه ردًا على هجمات 11
سبتمبر ، حيث بدأ الزواهي في أن يصبح
صوت آل-  القاعدة تسخر من
الأمريكيين الأمريكيين ، يجب أن تسألوا أنفسكم
لماذا كانت كل هذه الكراهية ضد أمريكا
بعد الغزو الأمريكي لأفغانستان
بن لادن والزاوي هاربين
أحيانًا؟  في كثير من الأحيان ، قُتل كل من
زوجته وبناته في غارة جوية أمريكية استهدفته ،
لكنه استمر في إصدار رسائل حول
مواضيع تتراوح من الحرب في العراق إلى
هجمات مترو أنفاق لندن في عام 2005
، وبينما كان دائمًا الخيار المحتمل
لخلافة أسامة بن  لادن
استغرق الأمر عدة أسابيع من المنظمة
للإعلان عن ترقيته للظواهري
ليس كاريزميًا
لأنه لم يشارك في
القتال في وقت سابق في أفغانستان
، لذا أعتقد أن لديه الكثير من
المنتقدين داخل المنظمة
وأعتقد أنك ذاهب إلى  أراهم يبدؤون
بأكل أنفسهم من الداخل
أكثر فأكثر دون أن يكون بن لادن
لا يمكن أن تكون القاعدة هي
نفسها الفكرة التي جسدها أسامة بن لادن ،
لقد كان هذا الشخصية الكاريزمية للانضمام
إلى القاعدة ، لقد رأيت أنك
أقسمت له يمينًا شخصيًا ذهب الناس وماتوا.  ليس
لأيمن الزواري أو خالد الشيخ محمد
ولكن بالنسبة لأسامة بن لادن يقول خبراء الإرهاب
أن القاعدة
لا تزال تتمتع بجاذبية كبيرة كمصدر إلهام للجهاديين في جميع أنحاء العالم